Hello, and welcome to this session on Cinematics for Architecture in Unreal Engine.
My name is Amer Yasin, and I will be your instructor.
This is a follow-up to the Sequencer for Architecture introductory class.
Make sure you have familiarized yourself with the process of using Sequencer in UE5 before
tackling this one.
Here you'll learn about creating cinematic shots in Sequencer by experimenting with
cine cameras and what they have to offer.
You'll learn how to create and set up such cameras, how to animate them in different
ways, and ultimately how to output high-quality stills and animations to disk using various
techniques, including Movie Render Queue.
Let's start.